so I wanted to answer the question is
keto low-carb actually safe for the
thyroid or is it gonna end up ruining
your thyroid and creating damage let's
take a look at that here we have the
thyroid it's in the base of the neck
right down here about two and a half
inches wide the thyroid makes t4 it's
controlled by the pituitary a hormone
called thyroid stimulating hormone so
this basically is what causes the
thyroid to make tea for now t4 is
actually a pre hormone or inactive
hormone it doesn't really do much it has
to be converted to t3 the 4 and a 3 are
the number of iodine molecules so what
it strips off an iodine molecule becomes
t3 becomes active this happens through
the liver and the kidneys 80% of the
conversion happens to the liver and 20%
happens to the kidney so when you go in
a keto or low carb eating plan it is
actually true that t4 will decrease up
to 40% now that's pretty scary if you're
only focusing on this one factor but
we're gonna take a look at the whole
picture so many people take this out of
context and they end up giving you the
wrong information so here's the facts
there are no studies out there that show
any negative effects on the thyroid when
you go on a ketogenic plan or a low carb
diet 0 studies in fact and this is
interesting despite this drop by 40%
there is no drop in actual metabolism
and the way that someone is diagnosed
with hypothyroidism which is a slow
thyroid is through thyroid stimulating
hormone but guess what when people do
keto or low carb diets this does not
change so this is 0 also t4 doesn't
change only t3 and this is with all
types of populations athletes super
athletes overweight people so how do we
explain this well here's what's really
happening
t3 is becoming more sensitive I mean
think about insulin when you do a key to
a plan or you're doing low carb you're
fixing insulin resistance you are making
insulin more sensitive what does that
mean it means that that hormone is
working more efficiently it's working
better instead of getting 25 miles a
gallon you're now getting 40 miles of a
gallon so you're actually getting better
gas mileage with this t3 becoming more
sensitive I believe what's really
happening is that high carbohydrate
diets increase the need for a more
thyroid hormone and that's why it's
higher and then you go to ketogenic
low-carb diet which I believe really is
a normal way of eating it's a healthy
way of eating this goes down 40% which
is not abnormal that number is actually
normal on what our bodies were designed
to use so in summary when you do a low
carb keto plan you're actually improving
the efficiency of the thyroid you're not
making it worse this is not worse you're
just not needing so much t3 does that
make sense
I hope so thanks for watching hey if you
haven't already subscribed press the
button below and I will keep you in the
know hey that rhymed